with more than 100 thousand russian
troops on ukraine's border the pentagon
says they expect tens of thousands more
in the coming weeks
[Applause]
at a press conference the top u.s
military leadership said they didn't
think the decision to invade has been
made but warned it would be horrific if
it happened given the type of forces
that are arrayed
the ground maneuver forces the artillery
the ballistic missiles the air forces
all of it packaged together if
that was unleashed on ukraine it would
be significant very significant and it
would result in a significant amount of
casualties
ukrainian president voldemort zielinski
is trying to reassure his people saying
we've seen russian buildup forces like
this before the warning from the
chairman and the joint chiefs of staff
not like this but this is different
so we'll we'll continue to monitor it
very very closely but yes it does feel
different but the biden administration
is under pressure to have the military
do more issue sanctions now and then
escalate send american and nato soldiers
around russia to reinforce we're not
giving an itch when it comes to nato
the pentagon is ready to send a small
contingent of troops to eastern europe
he can order his troops away
he can choose dialogue and diplomacy
whatever he decides
the united states
will stand with our allies and partners
so if russian troops move in russia will
pay an immediate economic price
even if that means ukrainians will pay a
much heavier one in the short term